what up space fam goes into your DG
fanboy here for anime uproar and I'm
back at it again to talk about the
latest and extremely interesting
developments and a demon slayer story in
fact the secret behind all breadth
styles and demon slayer marks was
explained so definitely stay tuned for
that if you enjoy seeing demons their
content on this channel make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when new Demon
Slayer videos drop for more Demon Slayer
content and crucial updates about the
new movie and seasons make sure to
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime up drawer there will be spoilers
in this video we are talking about the
latest chapter after all now it's how
further ado let's jump into the manga
chapter 178 was entitled even if you
reach out your hand in this chapter
Kakashi both sad tale continues and I'm
ecstatic because we get more information
about the life of your Ichi
so last chapter we learned a lot Kakashi
bo was spoiled by his father while you
teach he was almost killed and treated
like a cursed child by that same father
goody she helped take care of his sick
mother while Coco Sabo trained in the
art of the sword and in other privileged
things to everyone's surprise one day
the untalented yo deep she turned out to
be an amazing swordsman who far
surpassed his older twin brother Kakashi
bow and skill as a result your ichi was
going to take oka sheeples place as heir
and kuku shiva was going to be disowned
and placed in a temple however before
that happened
UDT left after his mother passed away
and no longer needed his help he left so
that cocoa sheba wouldn't have to give
up his privileged life and he took the
crappy flute that Kakashi bow gave him
to since he loved his older brother and
he considered the flute his most prized
possession despite the fact that your
each he had a less privileged upbringing
from the beginning sacrificed everything
for his brother and truly loved his
brother more than anyone else
kikuchi bow still hated him he was
extremely jealous jealous of your DG's
flawless sword skills and flawless
character this chapter starts with Coco
Shiva wishing that his little talented
brother would die he wishes that you
each she was never born his existence
according to Coco's she bow defied the
laws of nature we jump back into the
flashback and we discovered that your
Ricci's father tried to
Junichi to come back but he wasn't at
the temple he disappeared without a
trace
they didn't know if it was kidnappers or
a bear attacked him but it didn't matter
for ku ku Shi Bo the point was that his
wish came true his talented brother who
was an endless source of frustration for
Koko she bo was gone as a result he
lived a peaceful life for the next 10
years
he even got married and had children
Moochie ro the mist pillar was in some
way descended from one of these children
according to Goku she bow every day was
so tranquil during this period of his
life that it was even somewhat boring
the floor time felt extremely slow and
we seen a cuckoo she bo had a peaceful
smile on his face suggesting that he
very much enjoyed this period of his
life he could have died a happy man if
things stayed the same however it wasn't
meant to be everything changed with a
demon Nation attacked as they tend to do
more specifically one demon attacked the
place where Koko she was camping the
demon killed many people and all of a
sudden the time that felt like it was
frozen began to move again long lost
little brother Yuri she showed up and
saved Kakashi Bo from the demon but not
before the demon killed Kakashi will
subordinates ironically if you teach he
didn't say publishable at this point he
never would have become kakushi bo in
the first place he would have died a
pretty peaceful and happy man you know
besides the demon killing him part
however yo Deecee does save him and as a
result Koko she was life is forever
changed even as your duty saves him with
an emotionless expression Kukoc evil has
a worried and shocked expression on his
face in part he feared the demon and in
part he was shocked at how completely
different UDT was now compared to when
they were kids he had not only mastered
the sword he could now easily defeat in
human opponents like demons all of a
sudden the 10 years of peace were over
the moment Kakashi bow saw your Ichi it
destroyed his serenity his stomach
burned with jealousy and hate your Ichi
after saving his brother's life again
after so many years
apologizes of all things not only does
he not expect praise for his actions he
is sorry that he couldn't save Kakashi
both subordinates asked o Buechele
points out your Ichi was strong and he
was a person of faultless character he
accomplished superhuman things but never
let any of it go to his head after
seeing him coco she would decided that
no matter what the cost he had to make
your ichi strength
sword skills his own however it's too
bad that he didn't make his goal to be a
person with a faultless character like
your Ichi that would have led down a
path of serenity for Kakashi Bo but he
desired the power at the cost of
everything else as a result he abandoned
his home his wife and his children and
chose the path of a Demon Slayer
just like your Ichi did this is where we
get some interesting information
apparently your ichi taught many people
sort in breathing techniques but no one
could match him most people could not
learn the breath of the sun' style as a
result your ichi changed a breathing
technique in order to suit each person
skills and capabilities thus this is how
all the different breath styles came to
be they were all adapted from you at
each his original breath of the Sun
technique water mist fire and all the
others were created because people
couldn't learn breath of the Sun the
strongest in original form not only was
your DG behind all breathing styles
he was also behind the markings that
demon Slayers developed as far as we can
tell your ichi the first breath user was
also the first one with the mark because
of him the number of marked wants
increased and the power of the other
demon Slayers rose even Kakashi Bo
developed a mark and his was identical
to your each ease but he still wasn't
good enough to master the breath of the
Sun he could only learn an offshoot of
it later called breath of the moon
cuckoo she will really thought that he
could catch up to you at each sheet if
he just kept working hard and training
but he couldn't and that fact frustrated
him to no end then to make matters worse
the mark once began dying one after
another
apparently the mark just gave them more
power in exchange for their lifespans so
what was called the golden era of demon
Slayers was about to end soon it seemed
like the skilled demon Slayers were all
about to die Coco she will realize he
had no future he didn't have time for
any more training he sacrificed
everything his serenity and his family
in order to become as strong as your
Ichi and he couldn't do it all he
managed to do was shorten his lifespan
in the process that's when moves on the
demon king of Pop approached him moves
on explained to Coco SIBO that if he
became a demon he could live forever it
would give him a chance to master
breathing techniques and perhaps surpass
his brother in power and
skill of course Coco Chabot accepted
this offer he already sacrificed
everything he could up to that point
why not sacrifice his humanity - why not
Double Down
yet it still wasn't enough he met you at
Ichi again when you're Ichi was an old
man past the age of 80 this is the part
of the story that we already knew you at
each he had transcended the laws of
nature
he lived past the age of 25 despite
having the mark not only that as an old
man he was still way stronger than the
eternally youthful demon Kakashi Bo not
even Mouzon the strongest demon could
defeat or harm you Ichi only old age
could end his life so he died undefeated
he died right after he showed Kakashi Bo
that despite all of his sacrifices he
still couldn't approach his little twin
brothers power and skill then we finally
see what happened after your Nietzsche
died standing up like a boss not even
old age and death could bring this epic
character to his knees kakushi both
frustrated and consumed with hate sliced
your DG's lifeless body only to discover
that your ichi still carried the crappy
fluid kokeshi bo had given him so long
ago yo Deecee has said before when he
was a child he thinks of the flute as
Kakashi bow in other words he never
abandoned kakushi bow or left him behind
he always cared about his brother and in
a way carried him with him at all times
upon seeing this Kakashi bow cannot help
but cry he keeps trying to deny the fact
that he loves his brother back
he keeps saying to himself that he hates
you - Ichi that seeing his face makes
him sick that hearing his voice makes
him so angry his head hurts even though
he's forgotten the faces of his father
mother wife and children he still
clearly remembers you to each his face
for kakushi bow your Ichi was the
unequaled son and all the humans around
him had no path other than yearning
reaching out their hands and writhing in
agony until they became ashes in other
words your teaching was untouchable
people could strive for his level of
skill but they would never be able to
achieve it kikuchi bo could never grab
hold of that skill just like we could
never grab hold of the son he couldn't
keep a hold on anything not his family
or his humanity he explains that he
abandoned all of his morals and
principles he cut down his own
descendants and completely abandoned
being a samurai but none of it
was enough coca Sheba remembered when
your DG told him that those who mastered
their paths all reach the same place but
Coco Chabot said he never did he could
not see the same world that UD she saw
he reveals that after you teach he died
moves on in kakushi beau made sure that
all the swordsmen who knew son breathing
and its forms were killed but it somehow
remained in this world and came back in
the form of Tangier oh so your teaching
was right when he used to smile and now
worry all those years ago he knew that
people would eventually come that would
succeed him and he was right his legacy
managed to live on while Coco Chabot
couldn't leave anything behind he even
cut down his own descendant mu Ichiro
Kaku Shiva asks why they are so
different he wonders why he was born he
directs his question to you at Ichi
before he disappears revealing that he
kept the crappy flutes after killing you
leeching now wow what a chapter it is
clear that Coco's evil had very mixed
feelings about his brother right until
the end
although he kept trying to convince
himself that he hated his talented
brother who loved him more than he loved
anyone it seems like it wasn't that
simple he actually cared about you at
Ichi - and of everyone he remembered his
face he cried when you reach he died and
we saw that he still had the flute
kokeshi bow back then was trying to
completely get rid of his humanity he
wanted to kill you - Ichi so nothing
human remained and he could pursue pure
power without anything getting in the
way however the fact that he kept the
flute shows that he didn't succeed in
completely discarding his humanity and
becoming a monster he was trying to
convince himself that he hated yuuichi
but after this chapter it seems like he
was trying to mask the fact that he
still loved him he was still carrying a
teacher with him and that's symbolized
by the crappy flutes
it seems like Coco's evil was not as big
of a monster as he wanted to convince
himself he was and so it finally seems
like a cushy Bo's story is over
underneath the monstrous demon there was
still some humanity left all along he
wanted to be as strong as his brother
and he sacrificed almost everything to
do it but he could never succeed
nevertheless he still cared about his
brother and he still couldn't bring
himself to completely discard his
humanity
kikuchi Bo's tail really illustrates how
dangerous enemy can be it can turn us
into monsters
kikuchi bow should have looked at your
each is flawless character and tried to
emulate that he should have practiced
being selfless disciplined moral and
tranquil he should have been thankful
for what he had for instance he had a
family of his own while your each he did
not but he could only focus on what he
didn't have namely yo Deecee sword
skills growing up yuuichi acted like a
stoic aka one who practices stoic
philosophy he expected nothing and
accepted everything yes he works hard to
carry out his duty but he didn't need to
be the best
he wasn't jealous of others he was
content with his life even though he was
treated like the inferior brother and
had a much more difficult upbringing all
pain comes from our desire for reality
to be different than it is however if we
just accept our reality and learn to be
grateful for what we have
we like kid your ichi will not need to
experience the pain and frustration that
turned Coco SIBO into a monster this
doesn't mean that you shouldn't try to
improve you should and your Ichi
constantly used and as a result improved
upon his sword skills however even as
you improve you should enjoy the journey
rather than being obsessed with some
external outcome the act of improvement
should be its own reward and not a means
to some goal that you may never attain
if we decide that we won't be happy
until we're the best at something like
hakushi bo did then we'll never be happy
even if we achieve that goal well feel
empty inside and immediately create a
new goal and it'll become a never-ending
cycle of unhappiness moving towards
external goals can be good but until we
can be happy right here and now with
what we have chances are we'll never be
happy this was kokeshi Bo's issue he
could have been grateful for having a
beautiful family and for not having to
kill demons every day of his life he
could have been content with living a
peaceful life with them he could have
appreciated the fact that he was one of
the best swordsmen in the world and if
he really wanted to he could have
consistently worked on improving his
skills while enjoying the process he
could have counted himself blessed
because his father made him the heir to
his fortunes and his brother loved him
more than anything he could have lived a
truly blessed existence
if only he didn't let his need to be the
number one strongest swordsman ruin his
life
cuckoo she will had a full glass right
in front of him but he was too busy
complaining about the half-empty glass
at the other end of the room it's funny
actually this advice seems like the
opposite of what you get in most shown
in also times shown and promote the idea
that you can and should be number one in
the world at something and there's
nothing wrong with trying to be number
one but the key is enjoying the process
you have to be in love with the journey
of trying to get there
rather than being obsessed with the
outcome if you tell yourself you can't
be happy until you become number one
then you'll always feel frustration and
anxiety and that will most likely get in
the way of you becoming number one the
key is to let go of the outcome and do
your best that way you give yourself the
best chance to succeed ironically the
more desperately you need something the
less likely you are to get it you didn't
even want to be the number one samurai
but he was while Koko she will
desperately wanted to be number one but
all that intense desire got him was a
life filled with pain and unhappiness
my advice is think of a destination or
dream you'd like to get to then figure
out the process that is most likely to
get you there then commit to the process
and enjoy the journey while not worrying
about the destination aka the external
outcome you trying your best should be
its own reward
if Koko Chabot followed this life advice
he would have experienced more happiness
and arguably more success so that is my
take on Koko Cibo he wasn't a complete
monster but he had the wrong approach to
life and it ruined him
UDT was always selfless and because of
that his legacy lived on someone he
saved ended up passing on his teachings
to their descendants however Koko Cibo
lived a completely selfish life he left
his family and even killed his own
descendants because they stood in the
way of his misguided goals so to answer
kakushi bose why could I not leave
anything behind question it is because
his selfishness led him to destroy his
own legacy to his wine the world was
ever born question it was to teach
others about the dangers of a selfish
and unprincipled life we all have the
potential to become like your Ichi or
Kakashi Bo at least character wise and
who we become largely depends
the choices we make and the actions we
take anyways I can do an entire video
about the philosophy of Demon Slayer and
you guys can let me know if you want to
see that in the comments but for now I
should probably wrap up this chapter
review thank you for watching and let me
know what you thought about this chapter
if you like this video make sure to
smash that like one to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
bring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when future
chapter reviews drop for more Demon
Slayer content and crucial updates about
the movie and new seasons make sure to
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime up drawer link in the description
a big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible i especially want
to thank our pro here to your patrons
the one and only gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson Kings eldress angel
Cruz Steelers boy Pablo atropos Wraith
fitty dalla beat accordion Anatoly
Cassatt Suki and Lord a bird and are the
one tier patrons the ones who stay atop
all clans Steven and Radha a Lola autumn
Maddie Mac 239 makoto-kun and ya boy
Seth if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon economy out floor and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private page and only this
cord so check out patreon.com slash
anime out drawer link in the description
if you're interested you can also now
join the YouTube channel and support
more content that way if you prefer
while still getting the same great
benefits anyways thanks again so much
for everything and until next time see
you space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]